[Music]
and they're off are you going to be the
next prime minister
that's his hope rishi sunak the first
big name to enter the race
someone has to grip this moment and make
the right decisions
that's why i'm standing to be the next
leader of the conservative party and
your prime minister
in a glossy social media video the
former chancellor focused on his
family's immigrant story pitching
himself as the serious candidate our
country faces huge challenges
the most serious for a generation
do we confront this moment with honesty
seriousness and determination
or
do we tell ourselves comforting fairy
tales that might make us feel better in
the moment but will leave our children
worse off tomorrow
rishi sunak's leadership hopes seemed
dashed just months ago after his wife's
tax arrangements came under fire
but his decision to resign and call time
on the prime minister has put him back
in contention the things the public
tired of with boris johnson are the
things we need to change i think they
want somebody with honesty
and integrity somebody who tells the
truth
and somebody also is honest with them
about the difficulties he'll be running
two jeremy hunt a contender from the
center of the party
sajid javid likely to step into the race
as well which could stretch to more than
a dozen contenders
in under two weeks mps will have
whittled down the field of names to
succeed boris johnson to just two
but the sheer number of candidates that
will have to have been excluded by that
point to get there means the process
will be rough and messy and lacking in
much rigor
rishi sunak is positioning himself as
the anti boris johnson candidate he's
likely to point to polling suggests that
he's the only one who could beat
labour's kirstarma
the labour leader free to fight on
cleared by police drawing an unavoidable
distinction what you will always get
from me is someone who believes honesty
and integrity matter
someone who will work every day
for the good of the country buoyed by
the largest labour poll lead this year
kyostama is now demanding an election
we've been stuck in the middle of a cost
of living crisis with the cub with
government that can't deliver well the
prime minister's not fit to be prime
minister the conclusion at last of the
parliamentary conservative party britain
deserves that fresh start
that can only come with a change of
government
expect frenetic activity in here next
week rounds of voting will knock out
candidates one by one the votes of 358
tory mps behind closed doors once again
determining the direction of the country
sam coates sky news westminster